Welcome to "Google Developers
Weekly" for October 28, 2013.
I'm Louis Gray, and this
is our highlight reel
of what's happening in the
world of Google Developers,
on the set and off.
As an innovator,
you want to protect
your work and your inventions.
In the first episode
of "Root Access"
this week, Don Dodge talks
about New Zealand's move
to ban software patents,
how skunkworks projects
in big companies operate, and
takes questions from viewers.
But as you no doubt
know, big ideas
don't always result
in big results.
In addition to hard
work and innovation,
sometimes you need to be lucky.
I joined Don to talk about the
intersection of skill and luck
and how companies
need to constantly
be aware of changes
in the market
to deliver what customers want.
From Berlin, Martin
Gorner is back
for another episode in the SQL
versus NoSQL debate, with guest
Nacho Coloma, the CTO of
Koliseo and author of SimpleDS.
The pair offer tips and tricks
to help you tackle new NoSQL
databases such as the
App Engine Data Store.
And from New York,
Ikai Lan shows us
the tricks he uses to
debug OAuth token issues
in the YouTube API.
He demonstrates how to use
our token info tool, as well
as some tricks for using the
OAuth playground for debugging.
And heavy page weight is bad
for your bandwidth [? belt, ?]
especially when you're browsing
the web on a mobile device.
Colt McAnlis, resident
web performance hacker,
tells us about new and exciting
ways to compress CSS, JSON,
HTML, XML, and JavaScript
data on the web,
and how GZIP sometimes helps
but can also get in the way.
And then we take GDL on the
road to the San Francisco office
of App.net, where Googler
Brett Slatkin talks
with Dalton Caldwell about their
platform as a service offering
and how it differentiates
from others in the market.
From our Android friends, we
saw a pair of shows last week.
First, the Android
design team, consisting
of Nick Butcher, Adam
Koch, and Roman Nurik
took the time to deliver
some best practices on how
to show photos and
thumbnails in your apps.
Bruno Oliveira followed on with
part three of his Play Games
series, focus on threading
and lifecycle management.
And a few months
ago, we announced
Google was making
the CardDAV contact
standard available to all users.
Now we've added some
cool features, including
big, high-resolution photos,
improved battery life and data
usage, and more.
There's also a new developer
doc you can check out
at developers.google.com
Also, for AdWords API users, we
announced that flexible bidding
strategies have now
graduated from beta.
This feature enables you to
set up your bidding strategies
and share them among
campaigns and ad groups.
You can also learn more on
the AdWords API documentation
on developers.google.com.
And to make sure that you never
miss a thing from the world
of Google Developers,
subscribe to Google Developers
on YouTube, and check
out the GDL schedule
at developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll
see you here in the studio.